il ya quelques mois twitter et facebook
ont décidé de censurer le compte de
donald trump alors président des états
unis d'amérique d'événements
spectaculaires souligne le pouvoir
monumentale que possède désormais les
réseaux sociaux et la responsabilité
énorme qui découlent de ce pouvoir
la diffusion massive de certaines
informations peu déstabilisé des
gouvernements et semer un chaos
sanitaire ce qui peut ensuite menacé le
bien-être la santé et la sécurité de
centaines de millions voire de milliards
de personnes à travers le monde
malheureusement le choix de ce qui sera
modérée ou diffuser massivement
aujourd'hui extrêmement opaque et
centralisée puisqu'il est décidée par
une poignée de dirigeants de grandes
entreprises ou dans certains cas par
certains gouvernements puissants or
toute entité qui les tient autant de
pouvoir qu'elles soient privées
gouvernementales ou associative sera
voué à recevoir des incitations mais
aussi des pressions et des menaces
venant de toutes sortes d'autres entités
la centralisation de la décision surtout
quand celle ci est opaque et c'est
malheureusement le cas actuellement pour
les entreprises privées et pour de
nombreux gouvernements
cette centralisation et cette opacité
sont alors une menace énorme pour
l'intégrité et décision dès lors pour
résoudre des problèmes éthiques comme la
suspension du compte de l'ancien
président trump ou pour résoudre les
millions de milliards de dilemme auquel
les algorithmes de recommandations sont
confrontés il semble critique de
concevoir des outils de prise de
décision à la fois plus collaboratif
mais aussi davantage transparent
aujourd'hui on va parler d'un article de
recherche absolument fantastique qui
propose justement de tels outils et
permet ainsi d'envisager un futur où
l'éthique des algorithmes les plus
influentes du monde sera déterminé de
manière collaborative et transparentes
on va parler aujourd'hui de l'un de mes
articles préférés de la recherche
académique moderne
wild eyes est un framework est très
général pour l'éthique collaborative qui
a été appliquée au cas particulier du
problème de dons de nourriture auxquels
est confrontée l'organisation à but non
lucratif 412 foudre excuse cette
association située à pittsburgh aux
états unis organisent la livraison de
dons de nourriture par des donateurs
comme des supermarchés pour des
bénéficiaires ont besoin de nourriture
comme des refuges du sdf plus
précisément lorsque les donateurs
veulent donner de la nourriture
typiquement parce qu'il s'agit de restes
invendus il appelle alors le 412 un
membre du personnel de 412 food rescue
note alors les paramètres du don comme
l'identité du donateur sa localisation
géographique et la quantité de
nourriture a donné cette personne doit
ensuite décider quel volontaire doit
aller chercher le don de nourriture et à
quel bénéficiaire
le volontaire doit livrer le dont
chacune de ces décisions est alors un
dilemme éthique
en choisissant de livrer un tel écoles
plutôt qu'à tel centre de sdf
le personnel de 412 food rescue refuse
indirectement un don au centre de sdf et
malheureusement lorsque la décision est
prise par un personnel humain il ya un
risque important que le personnel humain
subissent un biais systématique en
favorisant certains bénéficiaires plutôt
que d'autres par ailleurs le processus
de prise de décision de l'humain est
opaque ce qui peut être frustrant pour
les définissent hier alors défavorisés
enfin pour d'autres cas d'application il
pourrait y avoir un risque que ce
personnel humain soit influencé voire
manipulés par des entités qui exigerait
de cette personne qu'elle favorise
certains bénéficiaires plutôt que de
l'autre de façon de plus importante le
personnel humain ou mettrait alors les
préférences éthique des autres parties
prenantes affectée par la prise de
décision le donateur préférerait
peut-être que sa nourriture soient
livrés à des sdf d'une certaine région
l'école qui reçoit la nourriture
pourraient en fait préféré des dons
réguliers et vient peut-être de recevoir
justement des dons les bénévoles préféré
peut-être minimiser leur temps de trajet
quitte à voir un trajet un peu plus long
et le reste du personnel de
l'association 412 foudre a su
préférerait peut-être respecter certains
principes dans sa logique de dons de
façon plus générale il semble que dans
l'idéal toutes les personnes affectées
par une décision devrait être consultés
pour prendre sa décision
en fait il pourrait même être
souhaitable de consulter les personnes
qui ne sont pas affectées directement
comme l'exigé souvent les défenseurs des
droits de l'homme et de la femme
lorsque des atrocités dont il ne souffre
pas eux mêmes directement sont commises
dans des pays étrangers
cependant toutes ces consultations ont
malheureusement le désavantage
de nécessité beaucoup de temps et de
travail humain en pratique comme toutes
les organisations 412 poudre est ce qu
est une association avec des moyens
limités et avec des contraintes de temps
importante en particulier chaque
décision du bénéficiaire d'un don doit
être prise en quelques minutes seulement
il est alors impossible de consulter
toutes les parties prenantes dans cet
intervalle de temps et les parties
prenantes retrouverait ce même
certainement un tel engagement dans la
prise de décision trop contraignante et
donc indésirables en fait rien que le
fait d'avoir un personnel humain chargé
de prendre décision est en fait coûteux
pour l'association 412 food rescue s'il
était possible d'automatiser cette
décision tout en garantissant qu'elle
soit mieux prise que par le personnel
humain
ce personnel humain pourrait alors mieux
exploiter son temps par exemple on
partant à la recherche de davantage de
donateurs et de bénéficiaires pour ainsi
permettre à davantage de nourriture de
trouver preneur en demande avant que
cette nourriture ne périment
pour résoudre le problème de l'éthique
de la nourriture de manière
collaborative il des centrales de we
build et ice est de s'appuyer sur ce que
je vais appeler des représentants
algorithmique ou dit autrement au lieu
de solliciter les humains à chaque fois
qu un dilemme se pose
we build et va solliciter les
représentants algorithmique des humains
et les faire voter pour déterminer
quelle solution semble préférable
on peut y voir une analogie avec la
démocratie représentative en démocratie
représentative
l'élaboration des lois et les décisions
exécutives sont elles aussi trop
complexes ou trop fréquentes pour se
prêter à la sollicitation de l'ensemble
de la population
la solution de la démocratie
représentative c'est d'amener chaque
citoyen à élire non pas des textes de
lois ou des décisions exécutives
mais à élire des représentants qui eux
se charge d'écrire les textes de lois de
prendre des décisions exécutives et
alors dans l'idéal de la démocratie
représentative des représentants
démocratiques devrait alors parfaitement
représenter les citoyens qui les ont
élus
autrement dit ils devraient alors votez
exactement comme ses citoyens votent
aurait si on leur demandait de voter
cependant en pratique cette
représentation des citoyens est
généralement très imparfaite voire dans
la plupart des démocraties
représentatives à travers le monde
cette représentation est
catastrophiquement guézé et opaque
l'une des raisons à cela vient des jeux
politiques inéluctable entre les
représentants politiques surtout
maintenant que le travail de
représentants politiques correspondent
désormais généralement à une carrière
très compétitive pour les hommes et les
femmes politiques
or quand la compétition est rude les
incentives prédomine
et c'est sans doute pour cela qu'on se
retrouve aujourd'hui souvent avec des
politiciens qui font tout pour être et
rester au pouvoir
mais il ya une autre raison pour
laquelle la démocratie représentative
est voué à être gouvernés par des
représentants qui représente mal les
préférences de leurs électeurs
ces représentants démocratiques
représente aujourd'hui un goulot
d'étranglement informationnel après tout
chaque représentant démocratique
représentent souvent des milliers voire
parfois des millions d'individus
différents
il est alors impossible que ce haut
représentant représente fidèlement
chacun de ses électeurs
en fait il lui est même impossible
d'être adéquatement informés sur les
préférences de ses différents électeurs
pour contourner cette difficulté
informationnel oui bill et ray propose
de concevoir pour chaque électeur un
représentant sur mesure chaque
représentant est alors ultra
personnalisés chaque représentant
représentent les préférences
d'un unique électeur de plus parce que
c'est un algorithme ce représentant
algorithmique ultra personnalisé pourra
participer à un très grand nombre de
deals est distinct et être abondamment
tester et audités par son électeur
humain à chaque fois qu un dilemme se
présente
oui bill gates propose alors de
solliciter tous les représentants
algorithmique et de les faire voter la
solution qui gagne le vote des
représentants algorithmique sera alors
le choix éthique de will be here
il reste toutefois le pr
voir les représentants algorithmique
ultra personnalisé wibeez leahy propose
deux solutions pour y parvenir
d'un côté les électeurs peuvent
concevoir eux-mêmes leurs représentants
algorithmique intel algorithmes pourrait
être de la forme je préfère donner aux
bénéficiaires le plus proche où je
préfère donner aux bénéficiaires qui n'a
pas reçu de dons depuis le plus
longtemps
parmi l'ensemble des cinq bénéficiaires
de plus proche ou bien sûr on peut
imaginer des algorithmes plus
sophistiqués malheureusement cette
solution requiert une certaine aisance
avec le langage de l'informatique une
attention importante pour décrire soi
même ses propres préférences et même
avec ces compétences et cette dévotion
et claire explicitement nos préférences
est en fait une tâche très délicate
l'autre solution proposée par ugb idéale
consiste à se reposer sur le machine
learning plus précisément rue bidet
arrive alors posé des dilemmes à un
électeur typiquement il va lui proposer
un scénario où un donateur vient
d'appeler et il faut décider où le don
sera livrée parmi un ensemble d'options
avec différentes caractéristiques we
build est arrivé alors collecter la
préférence éthique de l'électeur pour ce
dilemme est pour toutes sortes de
dilemme similaire à partir de ces
données
oui bizarre il va alors concevoir un
modèle de l'électeur qui colle avec les
jugements fournis par les lecteurs le
modèle obtenu sera alors le représentant
algorithmique de l'électeur le principal
des avantages de cette seconde méthode
c'est que l'électeur n'aura pas écrit
lui-même son représentant à hugo
rythmique il doit donc faire a priori
confiance aux algorithmes de huy billy
ray pour construire cette confiance oui
bilal propose alors à l'électeur
d'interagir avec son représentant
algorithmique en testant son avis dans
d'autres dilemme mais surtout le gros
avantage de cette seconde méthode c'est
qu'elle est beaucoup plus facile à
utiliser pour la plupart des électeurs
c'est une approche qui semble
particulièrement bien se prêter à la
mise à l'échelle et donc à la
participation d'un très grand nombre
d'électeurs avec des bagues en divers et
variés et surtout avec des degré
d'engagement inigo c'est pour cette
raison que cette méthode a aussi a été
proposé pour déterminer les tic des
voitures autonomes en situation de
dilemme via notamment des jugements
fournie sur le site morale machine ce
duo a mighty et pour déterminer les tic
du don de rein et c'est aussi pour cette
raison que c'est la solution qui a été
adopté par tournesol pour résoudre les
tics de la recommandation des contenus
en plus le permet
la borat yves d'après l'étude réalisée
par ses créateurs we build et à ya aussi
et surtout permis de rendre davantage
transparent le processus de prise de
décision de l'association 412 food
rescue et d'ainsi augmenter la confiance
des différentes parties prenantes ans
l'association en effet interviewé par
les chercheurs
une bénévole explique que c'est
certainement plus juste que quelqu'un
assis à un bureau qui essaie de
comprendre par lui-même ce sont les
cerveaux de tout le monde qui ont été
jugés importants pour cette décision
cela devrait être le plus juste possible
un personnel de l'association ajoute
qu'il est important d'obtenir l'avis de
toutes les personnes concernées pour
remettre en question les hypothèses de
l'organisation y accroître l'efficacité
de leur travail
l'un des membres de l'un des organismes
bénéficiaires partage ce sentiment en
affirmant qu'elle est prise de décision
sont plus juste en prenant la moyenne de
tout le monde
mon modèle n'est que mon expérience
ajoute-t-il je vois mon expérience
différemment de celle du voisin mon
expérience est subjective ceci dit de
façon plus intéressante encore will be a
surtout permis aux différentes parties
prenantes d'avoir une image plus
positive de l'association 412 food
rescue notamment quelles raisons alors
mieux compris la difficulté des dilemmes
éthiques auxquelles l'association est
constamment exposés tout en mesurant
mieux les préoccupations de
l'association pour l'équité de la
manière dont les destinataires des dons
sont déterminés hashtag c'est compliqué
voilà qui a permis d'augmenter la
confiance et la motivation a collaboré
avec l'association est peut-être mieux
encore les interfaces de we build et ike
et l'effort doit concevoir les
représentants algorithmique ont permis
aux différentes parties prenantes de
mieux comprendre et de gagner confiance
en les algorithmes utilisés par 412 food
rescue de façon remarquable un bénévole
initialement sceptiques a fini par faire
confiance avec tout son coeur à son
représentant algorithmique un personnel
de l'association initialement effrayé à
l'idée de concevoir représentant
algorithmique a fini par trouver web
idéal très raisonnable un donateur
enfants estime que sa confiance bien
aussi et surtout de son interaction avec
les développeurs qui l'ont rassuré en
montrant leur attachement aux
considérations éthiques
ceci étant dit la solution implémentée
par ubi d'eric n'a pas fait l'unanimité
en particulier un bénévole et un membres
de l'association ont questionné les avis
des différents électeurs en doutant à la
fois de la compréhension des enjeux par
les électeurs et de leur capacité à
concevoir un représentant algorithmique
correct pour que we build deviennent
davantage ce qu'on voudrait qu'il soit
il serait peut-être pertes
donc de mieux identifier les domaines
d'expertisé des différentes parties
prenantes de mesurer leur degré
d'investissement cognitif et d'estimé
l'incertitude sur le fait que leur
plantant algorithmique soit correct
voilà de sacré défi pour la recherche en
éthique et en sécurité
des algorithmes
rarement une lecture m'a rendu
si enthousiaste que l'article oui les
rails cet article présente un framework
qui résout à merveille plusieurs des
défis que le professeur al mahdi el
mhamdi et moi avons soulevés dans notre
livre le fabuleux chantier plus encore
ce framework fantastique a été déployé
et son déploiement dans un cas pratique
montre à quel point il est pragmatique
et prometteur pour toutes sortes de
problèmes de prise de décision
automatique avec des enjeux éthiques
comme c'est le cas au hasard des
dilemmes des algorithmes de
recommandation et justement quelques
mois après avoir le wild et des
collègues et moi avons décidé d'adapter
oui beady eye à la recommandation de
contenu ainsi naquit tournesol tournesol
c'est notre proposition des tic
collaborative pour résoudre un joueur
les millions de milliards de dilemme
éthique qui détermine temps le présent
et le futur de l'humanité
mais bien sûr pour que cette éthique
collaborative fonctionne il est critique
qu'un très grand nombre de contributeurs
collaborent avec nous et conçoivent
leurs représentants algorithmique sur
notre plate forme pour qu'on puisse
ensuite déterminer des recommandations
qui résulte d'un vote d'un très grand
nombre de représentants algorithmique
divers et variés et conçu de manière
fiable plus que jamais pour résoudre
l'éthique de l'information
nous avons besoin de votre contribution